歡迎收看趙華
我是趙華
我是艾倫
今天大盤跟櫃買都跑去碰月線
碰到還真的給它急拉一波
真的耶
因為今天早上我有請教艾倫
艾倫說希望開低走高
我就想慢慢想吧你
可是因為這個
其實我比較在意的是這個量
量還是很小啊
對
所以我覺得
可是今天大盤
開低走高是拉快1000點
是
對
但成交量就還是7000多億
所以我覺得應該是防守有餘
但進攻要再看個幾天
不錯了啦
因為這兩天有時候一早開盤
我們自己打開APP
預估量5000億 超過分
嚇一跳
然後想說
可能因為南部現在有災情
有放假 無心做股票這樣子
對
可是後來因為可能盤面有些震盪
所以量還是有拉到六七千億以上
沒錯
不夠嗎
不夠啊
怎麼會夠呢
我們現在四萬多點呢
可是今天的收繳
有沒有意義呢
因为我们之前常常说
涨上来了嘛
稍微回档一下
休息一下都是正常的
但是什么时候再攻
可能就要抓一下时机点了
没错
好 那我们来看一下
因为这礼拜很重要一件事情
明天的凌晨
灰达的财报公布了
以及这个财政部美国的
他说要花一兆美元来救债市
有一句话叫做官官难过
官官是谁
官官难过
官官过
是
那今天的話艾倫會幫大家
從各個族群的龍頭體檢
因為龍頭復甦
整個族群就有可能復甦
沒錯 一方面是有些龍頭
確實已經創新高了
回到了這個7月之前的榮光
但是有一些是一去不復返
所以我們今天都會分別
根據有AI相關的一些龍頭
稍微幫大家看一下技術面上的型態
那當然我們一開始之前
還是跟大家看一下
這一個華許呢
準備來Jackson Ho演說了
是一個全球央行的年會
那目前这个
我觉得这个也有可能是让整个行情
稍微比较温吞的一个状态
因为大家就是在等嘛
到底会讲出什么东西
好 所以市场预期呢
会不会有一些FED的一个体制上的改革
那不会太着目于通膨跟货币决策的前景
就是一些前瞻指引
那这个其实应该就确定了
还有另外一个目前来说
他们也有一点生不了息的一个尴尬情况
就是美债殖利率
不管是10年起 20年还是30年起
全部都是創下了一个
近几年来的新高
尤其是30年起的
是的
这个金融海啸以来的新高
那就有点尴尬了
那尴尬到什么程度呢
尴尬到这个贝森特最近有说
有一个进兆美元的银弹
要准备回购美债9月9号开始
这个原本是要回购20亿
那现在可能一次要40亿
Double
对 为了就是要干嘛
为了就是要压这个债券的殖利率
那债券殖利率呢
为什么他们要压
因为目前美国政府
已经是财政赤字
对那这一些美债时间到要付利息
那就是美国政府要付
所以它如果利率越高
那当然付出去的钱越多
所以它不希望值利率越来越高
但相对的如果是这样子的话
那滑雪就很难升息
因为你的基准利率越高
美债值利率就会跟着越来越高
而且他们后来都发新还旧
那新的就越来越
值利率越来越高
没错那这个其实也蛮有趣的
就是其实我觉得这件事情
就是变相的QE
因为你回购债券回来
你就是向市场出钱
给钱
所以到时候
其实9月之后
我觉得行情
当然我们说基本面很好
但我觉得会有热钱效应
所以我觉得今年第四季
应该值得关注
因为除了基本面好
要卖梦之外
这钱每次都会有40亿进来
所以我觉得是值得注意的
当然这会变成是说
华许就有点进推两难了
因为我觉得它有点生不了息
虽然它讲得蛮硬派的
对 可是它应该
我觉得反而是
不升息不降息的機會
下半年是提高的
就讓它hold在那裡
沒錯
打太極
對 你就自己慢慢弄
我就不升息也不降息
好 那再來另外一個
就是這個國會女股神
裴若曦
沒錯 重壓這個B1
還有這個Intel
所以呢 大家如果有興趣的
可以去看高麗
因為高麗跟Blue Energy
是有合作的
對 是直接這樣子聯
對對對
好 這個
那看Intel的話呢
Intel的話可能看看聯電
聯電 看看矽晶圓
我們就自己可以幻想一下
不然就开付委托啦
去买BE或者是买这个英特尔
而且呢他们除了买现股之外
有买钱
好 再来我们看一下
刚刚讲到的就是
可能今年下半年
应该说不是下半年
第四季开始
第三季尾 第四季出
会有热钱出来
但是呢
我们在7月这波行情呢
散户呢
钱反而是热钱出托
M1B跟M2
是的 出现了一个死亡交叉
对
就热钱开始下滑了
没错
這個就會是一年以上的一些
可能定存等等
比較不能馬上隨手動用的資金
對 那兩個都是下滑的
但是下滑的過程中
這一個卻是比它來的低
所以就出現死亡交叉
沒有錯 死亡交叉應該是
這應該是股災以來首次
就是去年 去年以來首次
對 所以目前來說
其實成交量降低
一部分也有是
散戶近就可能不完了因為成交量確實這幾波降得非常的快所以可能前面那一波反彈做一些縮手 比如說可能停損
或是回成本 那看不懂
那我就後面可能也不想玩了
所以可能會觀望一陣子
因為我看到證券化播局了
去年11月有降下來
今年3月有降下來
就每一次散戶被燙到都有降下來
所以7月降下來蠻正常的
可是這個M1B跟M2
這個就比較異常了
比較異常了
因為它一年多以來
第一次出現這個死亡交叉
就市場的熱錢在退潮
沒錯 所以我們也只能期待一下
貝聖德如果跟著開始回購
有沒有一些熱錢在慢慢跑出來
它這個錢很重要
這個錢很重要
所以我們稍微注意一下
資金確實是有在退潮的
這應該是蠻明確的
好 再來我們看到了
就是大盤的狀態了
我們剛剛提到沒有量
確實你看這邊
這邊是盤整開始盤整
這裡成交量也一口氣
直接從兆元的量直接降到現在
有6000億就蠻厲害的
少好多
是的 那貴馬也是一樣
這一波下來呢
成交量也是一路的慢慢下降
那我們來看到大盤
今天我們剛有提到
開梯走高進千點
那進千點的狀態呢
再加上這個量呢
我也只會把它歸類在就是
底部有人會做防守
但是你要直接這樣子
去一個墊高的行情
我覺得成交量至少要8以上
当然就是能够来到一兆以上
那当然是最好
所以目前来说这个量
就会变成是跌
也跌不到哪里去
但是涨呢
也容易开高走低
所以就会变成是
就看个股表现了
尤其成交量变少
个股的表现延续性
又变得不太好
因为大家钱就这么少
那我今天炒完这一档
我隔天可能就直接换档
可能赚个10% 15%
短视经历一点点
有赚我就跑
直接跑下一档
所以现在呢
股票是难操作的
這個應該大家體感是滿明確的
好 可是大阪還是給大家一點信心
這裡拉第一段
那開始這邊震盪
我們在44200
對44200這邊
打了兩隻腳
這裡一隻 這裡一隻
所以這個地方剛剛提到的這個數字
然後再加上哪裡
再加上月線
今天撐住耶 對
月線關卡撐住
是的
所以這個短線我們觀察的支撐
就是44200
再加上月線的雙重支撐
均线跟K棒给的支撑
这两个地方
守两次了
这里也守一次
那再来呢
你行情要去电高
除了我们刚亮
要粗一点之外
我们这个小平台先做突破
因为这五天呢
其实你一眨眼回来看
在原点
今天很悲观
隔天又很乐观
结果呢
在隔天又很悲观
然后回头一看
怎么原地不动
就在这个区间内做震荡
对所以呢
目前来说
这里如果能够做突破
带量的攻击
那我觉得这高点
就很容易去做突破了
所以我們現在要等的是
進攻的訊號
防守是OK的
但是目前可能還沒有
明確的進攻訊號
等於現在證明有在守
是 對
所以這樣很好啊
就至少不用怕跳水嘛
我們現在也在等美股的表現
因為不是我們那樣說
美股也亮說
也亮說
大家都在等一下看輝達
有沒有一些激情出來
那貴買也是一樣
這裡也是月線 月線
那也是前低
盤中都跌破
但收盤有散回來
我覺得都還可以
所以這個貴買是
這個地方要突破
上市是这个地方要突破
才有机会有一个新的行情
看有没有办法去延伸出来
不管是大盘还是贵买都一样
所以这是我们要观察的
几个支撑跟压力
给大家讲清楚
好 再来看到台积电
台积电今天很猛
今天拉50块
开低走高50块
最后会拉尾盘
跟它也有关系
是的
台积电今天要站回全部均线
所以我们上次说
你跌破全部均线
你不要紧张
但你站回全部均线
你也不用太兴奋
因为高点要做突破
才是行情的延伸
低点要做跌破
它才會是空方行情的延伸
所以目前就在區間震盪
那尤其這個成交量
也都是持續萎縮的
所以就等一個方向了
跟大盤一樣
我們要等一個方向
好 我們看點刺激的吧
光寶可
因為剛剛那些都在橫盤
對
這是創新高的
是的
今天還在創新高
沒錯
光寶可呢
好厲害 快300塊了
那個時候開了一個漂亮的
這個
的好數字出來
是不是 看點開心的
沒錯
然後就一口氣來到前高
在這邊做震盪
晃了大概两三周
昨天涨停
今天呢
今天原本震荡很大
今天其实开高是被灌蛮重的
那尾盘大家整个行情一好
它就跟着收到一个相对最高点
所以这边是第一段
那这边有一个整理
那整理在昨天做突破
今天继续做延伸
所以虽然看起来像在追
但其实是一个整理以后的转折
就是盘整转多头
那我觉得后续还可以再观察一下
高架股有川湖
中架股有保科
好
那还有吗
可以了
可以了是不是
火种没有灭
OK OK
那火种没有灭的情况
刚刚艾伦有讲到
现在是有防守的
就要等上攻
当然美国
挥达还有这个
Jackson Hall
讲的利率的决策
会是一个很重要的观察指标
下一段节目
我们干脆就
几个产业的龙头
帮大家看
因为如果有人冲出去
那整体产业就有可能冲出去
等一下来盘点
好 來吧我們來看一下最近這個股價非常辛苦的回答
連續漆黑
對
這一片漆黑
但是你不覺得
它就像是一個成熟的倒碎嗎
就你說這樣向下彎嗎
重點是人家前面還打WD
然後彈上來就
不知道很奇怪
就以前都是開完財報開始跌
對
這個一次是財報之前開始跌
我跟你講一個好消息
根據統計啊
財報前面開始跌啊
財報開完還是會跌
好的 謝謝
所以我們就看這邊
財報公布完會不會破底這樣
是不是要這樣分析嗎
也不是啦
就是通常會蹲一下
然後就會上去了啦
對啦 那看回答
有沒有辦法來一個利多
因為前幾天
華人群還有飛來台灣
快閃喔
又趕快回去要主持這個財報會議了
沒錯
另外則是Varubin
能不能如期放量
好 就是Q4
目前來說好像這一季
還是認為數字會到
只是它往後遞眼
但數字不變
這個是後續可以去觀察
再來還有一個
就是大家對於
揮答AI央行的疑慮
它能不能講得
更清楚一點點
是的
所以這個是我們後面兩天
可以去觀察
揮答的財報的部分
當然等數字出來
我們就來看一下
市場怎麼反應囉
好
顯然這一次
AI央行的是比較新的
就跟當年大家在解釋
中國到底能不能出口一樣
可能它有一個好的解釋
市场就会比较容易理解
买单
没错
好 那我们今天
今天CPU是很强的
好
CPU我们之前也特别有聊过
以形态来说真的是蛮厉害的
是的
当时是帮大家找
没有涨那么多的
因为像联雅都已经在天上了
那落后的其实像零化音全新
也有在涨
华星光那时候真的很抵挡
涨了四成
没错
其实今天
这么猛
好
就猛了
OK 好
OK
今天601
今天601回到600關了
其實前面挑戰三次
都沒有站上
那今天是有站上600關
好那不管怎麼樣
其實今天的整個CPU
在11點多的時候
有足群性的起漲
今天是很晚才發動
沒錯 其實不只他們
光盛 上全 東點光電 前頂
那一些其實都有拉一個大紅K出來
但這種是不是比較像隔日沖的手法
有可能
所以明天大家稍微注意一下
那當然如果隔日沖換手成功
它還是會有高點
只不過就稍微關注一下
這個比較偏無尾盤在拉的
比較有機會是
明天開高會被倒下來
明天如果開太高
大家就不要追了
當然如果震盪完
又開始有一些下影線
還是什麼樣的形態
再做介入就好
不過CPU確實今天是
盤面的亮點之一
不過今天我們要跟大家講的
就是這幾個都是今年
或者說去年
都非常夯的一個族群
我們今天來幫大家看一下
這些個股的形態
现在有没有什么样不同的变化
好
有记忆体ABF CCLO
封测被动元件
其实还很多啦
我还想要讲
比如说散热啊
对散热人家起雄创新高
因为太多啦
这里面的形态完全大不相同
我们先来看的就是记忆体的奈亚科
它很厉害了吧
很厉害
世界级的奈亚科
是的
奈亚科在前一阵子
这一波反弹的行情
是有创下历史新高的
那有的是可能连反弹30%都不到
没有那么过分 50%都不到的
好 那南雅科呢在近期
进入了一个高档的震荡
因为你可以发现
像是美光也在高档做一些震荡了
那不过呢像是三星海力士
这一波其实都是反弹快半三腰而已
那南雅科是可以直接创新高的
所以南雅科的走势确实这一波是强势的
那近期当然我们就等一个
有机会等一个新的买点
因为它目前守住了这个缺口
在高档做区间震荡
那不过5日均跟10日均线
也在昨天刚跌破
刚跌破过程中
这边如果能够守好
那我会觉得挑战高点
挑战高点
这边再看有没有机会
拉出一个新的趋势
所以我觉得其实今天
这根就很漂亮
对 因为今天是
站回全部均线
那碰前低
我觉得就很不错
所以明天可以看一下
有没有可以延续性
可以拉出来
这是南雅科
这个是强势的反弹AI股
好
再来我们看到的是
这一波也是强势的反弹AI股
就是新星
好 ABF栽办
这个一个族群是强势中的强势
没错
它波动很大
是的
星星这一波反弹上来
也是创下了历史新高
当然因为它历史新高
这边是没有创下来的
因为南电跟景硕
这边是有创高的
不过今天南电跟景硕的形态也好看
等一下
没有等一下
大家回去自己看
因为我只有讲星星而已
大家自己开框
另外两档也好看
对
因为其实这一次星星
下来修正的幅度比较轻
景硕跟南电
它是回到了季線的位置
但今天同步碰季線
都跟星星一樣
開機走高
有拉長下引線
而且是紅K
重點是量還有放出來一點點
所以我覺得景碩
南電大家都可以一起進來看
那星星這一波
一樣在這邊反彈的時候
也是進入了一個整理
整理這裡打兩隻腳
這裡守住這個大紅K的低點
然後今天站回10日均
如果明天站回5日均線
其實我覺得就有機會
在這邊看有沒有一個
創歷史新高的機會
所以欣欣目前形態上非常的漂亮我覺得是好看的大家可以多關注的再來我們看的就是台光店台光店这一波也创下历史新高但这一波最强的其实是三哥
连帽 今天还涨停板
很厉害 这一波反弹
比较弱的是台药 二哥
二哥大概反弹 因为他前面其实
那一段是他涨最凶
他在反弹幅度大概到这里
就是大概一半左右
台光店他一样也是有创新高后的压回
所以有创新高的个股
其实我觉得都是好事
回測看深或不深
那接下來他來到了月線附近
今天有拉一個紅K起來
我覺得還差一點點
大家可以看五日均線有站回來
再考慮要不要做介入就好
也就是說低點有守
那站回五日均線是進攻訊號
到時候如果你有做介入
這個低點就會是跌破後你的停順點
然後我覺得就相對好抓
因為你看這邊
都不會是值得關注的訊號
每天都是往右下方移動
那今天難得拉一個角
看能不能往右上方移動
如果有那今天的低點
就可以视为短线的重点支撑
因为刚刚有提到整体来说
应该是有防守对不对
所以它到月线如果没有跌破
应该也算是
我们在操作股票上面的
一个支撑点到了吗
没有错
而且我觉得它这一波
也没有到跌非常重
虽然也是很大的幅度一起勤扣
但是人家是创新高后一样
那个又不太一样
不太一样有创过高了
没错
那再来我们来看到的就是
比较扭一点点的
也代表整體的風測
事實上這波反彈上來
也比較牛喔
是的喔
彈了一段之後就開始橫盤了
沒錯喔
我們看到了
基本上七月的股票
大概都是漲這樣
對 大家漲一樣
但是反彈的狀態就不太一樣
你看瑞瑞光現在反彈的幅度
大概就接近50%
所以其實它沒有彈得很兇
那目前來說
彈上來到這個地方之後
也開始在這邊做橫盤震盪
也就是說它下也下不去
但是你要再向上墊高
目前好像資金似乎不在這裡
但是呢 如果以日月光啊 晶圆店呢
可能下半年的营收表现来讲
其实我觉得会偏委屈
它的股价啦 对
会股价偏委屈
但目前资金动能确实不在这里
所以呢 如果你要买像这种形态
就是日月光嘛 应该大家也不怕它倒嘛
对不对 难听点是这样嘛
世界第一大风测场
对 那目前来说就是一个大的区间在这里
所以呢 要真的真的有行情去做启动
那当然这个高点要去做一个突破
那目前來說是沒有去做突破的
但低點都有在做防守
今天也是一樣持續守好
那就是等一個站回全部均線
然後站回高點
那這個行情才有機會
原來一波爆發性的成長
股價才有爆發性的一個機會
他們可能跟台積電對不對
供應鏈例如設備也是這樣子
都比較牛皮一點
沒錯
所以如果台積電今天有一個
比較明確的發動
可能整體供應鏈
就會有比較明顯往上走
整體Cowars應該就有機會動一波
新晋风中Course也是功不应求
没错 但是目前似乎
资金不想买这一块族群
可能去买海了
好 再来我们看到最辛苦的
相对辛苦的就国具
不晓得在上面的朋友还好吗
因为涨了
但真的谈不回
不要说远点
可能一半都有点点吃力的情况
它又下去回测500块了
没错 我们刚看到了
最差的状态应该是日月光
但日月光也站回了季线
但是国具呢
连距离季线的位置
都还有一定的乖理
那这一波反弹
从400多弹到600多
其实也还好
对啊我们这边是
1220下来的
这边膝盖展嘛
那膝盖展弹了大概
这样弹起来可能
连这边的40到50%都不到
也就是说呢
其实大家可以蛮明确的注意到
国具的走势
在这一波反弹是比较弱势的
那比较弱势该怎么办
没能怎么办
如果你是买在800以上
900以上的
那你這邊也不太會賣了嘛
那就只能等了
等到什麼時候
等到哪一天
開始又有新的一個題材
去運轉的時候
因為像我也有聽到
有人說法是
國具是漲價題材
是
主動元件
被動元件 實行元件
都漲價題材
那還有像PCB這些
也都是漲價題材材料類
那這一波漲價題材
最受惠的是誰
是記憶體
所以記憶體的股價
它如果沒有一個延續性拉出來
其他漲價題材
可能延續性要拉出來的
的積極也會更低
所以記憶體一定要先強
那後面整個漲價題材才會有
大家透過這樣的方式去找
有沒有一起漲價的利多
去反映在其他族群身上
所以國際目前來說
以題材來講可能還差一點點
那以基本技術面上來講
這邊回測到前低附近
如果有守好
頸線能夠做突破
這邊的大底部才會有確立的訊號
那到時候看要怎麼去做一個
形态上的转强
所以目前来说
观察的就是这个高点的位置
何时能做突破
才有机会迎来一波
新的反弹的契机
是 因为涨价看记忆体
记忆体平均是涨了
大概有四倍之多
所以能够续涨其他的涨价题材
才有办法延续
再来就是升级的题材
可能升级的题材
就是看PCB为主了
但被动元件在升级上面
是没有像PCB这么样的明显
所以这些都是要
一并来做观察的
那如果需要今天节目
所有的图卡资料我们有免费提供
但是要希望大家订阅一下
我们赵华艾伦说的YouTube频道
我们会放在首页的贴文栏